gram Stefan clear value talkx before
they're YouTubers what were they doing
Graham Stefan was doing real estate
clear value talkx like owns maybe an
accounting firm or something like that
and so coming from those backgrounds
right they have real world experience
they're not just like hey here's some
random business ideas or ways to get
rich honestly a lot of Finance YouTubers
like they don't have any of that they've
never started business ever in the past
and now they're giving a business advice
that's crazy to me I want to make sure
I'm like as real as possible so I also
want to keep exploring business ideas
outside of YouTube while YouTube itself
is a business there are aspects of
YouTube that you can't find in other
businesses and then you're not going to
be like relatable to your audience when
promoting another business idea or
something like that